d'abord votre analyse de ces résultats
de ce second tour la gauche reculent la
droite l'emportent
c'est forcément une mauvaise nouvelle
mais la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
l'abstention continuer d'être très élevé
que le front national a gagné du terrain
sur le plan national et évidemment que
ces mauvaises nouvelles que des
départements passent à droite maintenant
je pense qu'il faut que les partis
traditionnels de gauche sache retenir la
leçon de cette élection qui semble à
nouveau être une élection d'enjeu
national c'est à dire que les électeurs
continuent apparemment à avoir un vote
un comportement qui est en réponse à
l'appréciation de la politique nationale
au niveau national il faut que les verts
rentrent au gouvernement il faut que la
gauche s'élargisse au niveau national la
question n'est pas celle des stratégies
entre partis c'est celle de la remise en
question du projet qui proposait aux
français c'est celle de la façon dont on
fait rêver dont on donne envie aux gens
de se sentir investi de se sentir
citoyen de vouloir à nouveau faire de la
politique et accepte et de effectivement
de faire confiance à des partis qui
aujourd'hui peuvent gouverner et c'est
celle de comprendre aussi ce mode de
comptes de comprendre la montée du front
national de comprendre l'abstention pour
moi c'est ça qui est problématique c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on se remet pas en
question et au niveau régional quel des
enseignements à tirer de ce scrutin au
niveau régional je peux pas encore vous
dire l'analyse la gelée pas on a les
résultats je n'ai même pas tous je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un vrai travail qui
doit être menée par les partis de gauche
par le parti socialiste en particulier
nous à europe ecologie les verts on
continue d'être dans un souci d'aller
vers le citoyen de d'engager un dialogue
et d'ouvrir le plus possible un autre
écoute et nos partenariats avec la
société civile pour effectivement saisir
ses rouages et être capable d'apporter
des réponses opérationnelles de man